It is Craft Week here at the show
and I am so excited to get my DIY on with our next guest.
He's an environmental lifestyle expert.
Really kind of first to the party, a true pioneer.
And his magazine, "Naturally, Danny Seo"
is jam packed with amazing tips and tricks.
I've actually read this issue front to back.
Please. welcome the original Danny Seo!
(audience applauding)
Hi, Drew.
That does look like a worn issue.
I got to get you a fresh one.
Well, I mean it, though.
You were really first to the party with all of this
and everybody has sort of,
I'm happy to say jumped on a bandwagon
to be more environmentally conscientious.
But you were doing it way before it was invoked.
I think it's now gonna be 30 years.
What are we gonna do today?
We're gonna dye common cotton things, paper things,
using this beautiful pink dye.
And can you guess what our one-ingredient
natural source will be?
Danny, tell us.
I mean, it's kind of obvious,
there's a bowl of avocados right here.
But we're using avocado pits.
I love that.
I have a real association and affinity for avocados
and their pits.
And I knew that about you.
You did?
(audience laughing)
Oops, ah, see how slippery they are?
I'm gonna grab it.
And as they say in "Pretty Woman",
slippery little suckers.
They're very slippery little suckers
and that's the avocado oil, that's the flesh.
So you have to clean them really well.
So dry them.
So we're gonna dry them
but you want to get all that oil off.
So you get them really wet,
and what you can do is take a little bit of just,
we have a little shot of soap.
You can take a little bit of soap
and just get it off because the avocado oil
all that's on the outside of the seed,
that can actually get onto whenever you're dyeing
and you don't want oil stains.
And what we have in the bowl here, we have about,
you need about six to eight avocado seeds
and you want them all to be clean.
You put them into a pot of water.
And then what you do
is that you simmer this for about 45 minutes.
Wait a minute.
Danny, this coloration is not from an avocado.
It is.
No!
Yes, you don't get a green dye,
you don't get a brown dye.
You get this beautiful pink dye from the seed.
You have got to be kidding me.
I thought we were actually working with
some type of color dye,
and I was like, "Oh, I love Rose color."
This is it.
This color is from the inside of the avocado?
Six avocado seeds and that's all you need.
Okay--
Easy.
So what we're gonna do is simmer this for about 45 minutes.
And then while we're doing that
you want to get your materials you want to dye ready.
I mean, this truly looks
like one of those stores you walk in and you're like
"Everything's so beautiful,
"but how much is it gonna cost," because it's so chic.
It kind of reminds me of that store
ABC.
(audience laughing)
We like the same things--
I want to high five but I can't.
So I see the pits and the color and everything,
but I want to know exactly how to do this.
You know, I'm not a pro pro at this,
but what I do know is
you want to fold whatever you're tie dyeing,
sort of as many ways that you want, twist it around.
But I just fold it a couple of times
and take the rubber bands,
and then you tightly
just wrap the rubber bands around and around.
So then after 45 minutes you want to let the dye cool down.
So you don't burn your fingers.
So it's not like boiling over,
and you just put it in the dye like this.
And then what I like to do, Drew,
is that I actually let it soak overnight.
But I also find that I let it sit out for a day or two
and then I wash it in cold water.
That's perfect.
Oh good!
Yeah, that's perfect--
I'm doing it right?
So we have a bowl of cold water here.
You're gonna take the one that's been cooking,
and the one that's already in there,
and we're just gonna rinse it out.
And then we get to do the fun part.
Get to do the reveal!
What you could do if you want to be really, really eco
is actually take them off and reuse the rubber bands.
Okay, goodness, I failed the first one.
I will succeed on the second.
Ready?
One, two, three.
Oh wow.
(audience applauding)
Danny, this is gorgeous,
and I have to tell you,
you can't really get this color in the dye world.
This is so unique.
You know what?
There's also a study that says that pupils dilate
when you see something that you associate with pleasure.
So guess what?
(audience laughing)
My pupils are like (makes weird noise).
Danny, this is so beautiful.
You can dry it and stuff it with a fresh pillow.
And I should point out
the tutorial for this avocado dyeing project
is in the winter issue which comes out in December 6th.
(upbeat music)